Je suis à non non non Lauren a évolué alors qu'il
racontait un couple minimal de Keith Haring
qu'il entend bien tous les deux vous êtes connu comme
le Michel-Ange du métro de New York
mais vous ne voulez pas être appelé les
t-shirts graphiques pourquoi
je veux dire je l'ai fait  faire dans le métro à New
York pendant cinq ans ouais donc c'est comme ça que j'ai
gagné le nom de bonne vidéo oui mais
le problème c'est que les gens ont tendance à
ne penser qu'à une seule chose quand ils
pensent à la ville et en réalité j'en ai fait
beaucoup de différentes  des choses quelle était l'
importance de l'université dans le ski et William
Burroughs dans votre décision de bien peindre
c'était deux des premières influences je
suppose que je veux dire les filles à cause de
l'idée conceptuelle de ce qu'il
faisait avec la littérature et avec l'
expérience psychédélique que vous connaissez  et
avec la façon dont il prenait les choses et les
découpait et changeait et
trouvait trouver une sorte de sens spirituel ou
psychédélique similaire à l'intérieur et
des choses normales non et pour Alec schinsky
était plus éloigné autrefois était son  les choses
étaient en quelque sorte similaires à ce que je
faisais à l'époque et j'explorais aussi des
choses en faisant des choses abstraites
qui évoquaient des images et d'autres choses
quand as-tu peint pour la première fois
dans un métro dans un appartement ou dans une
boîte de nuit quand était-ce  c'était dans le métro à
New York en 1980 c'était le début et
qu'est-ce que vous vouliez peindre dans le métro
j'ai commencé à dessiner à la craie parce que je
veux dire métro je ne dessinais pas sur les
murs je dessinais sur un
panneau publicitaire vide et ils ne le font pas
je n'avais pas assez d'annonces pour éditer une pièce vide alors j'ai
commencé à mordre et attiré par cette
chose avez-vous commencé à peindre dans le
métro parce que vous n'étiez pas en mesure d'
entrer dans un vrai musée à cette époque c'était
une sorte de musée pour vous  était l'
endroit idéal pour que les gens voient le travail
mais aussi à l'époque je ne vendais pas de
travail ou n'exposais pas dans des endroits sauf dans des
boîtes de nuit et dans de petits endroits des choses
comme ça
mais vraiment parce que le métro avait à New
York je veux dire il y a des centaines de
des milliers de  les gens tous les jours pour passer
devant le joint donc vous ne pouvez même pas dans un
musée vous ne pouvez pas demander cela et quand avez-vous
fait l'un de vos tableaux, je suis sûr que la
vraie musique
pour la première fois combien ont aidé plus tard
cependant par 19 1981  ou 82 a été ma première grande
exposition en galerie, puis en 8284 dans les
musées oh et j'ai traversé le MIT et le
monde toute la première et la première fois que je l'ai
vraiment rencontré, c'était au fond de ma
première grande exposition à New York avant
que je l'aie rencontré un  quelques fois, mais en
tant que fan, vous savez demander un
autographe et complètement nerveux et
ne savait pas quoi dire,
mais ensuite par le biais d'un ami commun qui
est venu à mon exposition et après la
première exposition, nous avons commencé à échanger du travail
et à devenir meilleurs et  de meilleurs amis
et puis je suis venu à chaque exposition
où ils sont venus au cours des trois ou
quatre dernières années sont devenus vous savez des amis pour
bavarder au téléphone dans la communauté
et vous avez rencontré bestia - Wow tout seul,
je connaissais John Michell quand je suis venu pour la première fois sur
terre  semaine où il est allé, il a grandi dans  New
York mais à Brooklyn mais il a commencé à
traîner sur la scène à New York à peu
près au même moment que moi, donc je l'ai
rencontré en 1981, la
meilleure voiture peinte avec le monde, mais vous n'avez
jamais fait pourquoi en partie parce que c'est
John Michell bit je veux dire II  J'ai fait comme
deux ou trois petits tableaux avec Andy
que nous avons donnés à Madonna pour un cadeau de
mariage quand elle est née tu as l'impression
que tes cheveux sont bien pliés d'une certaine manière je
veux dire c'est presque trop à prendre
tu sais que c'est comme ça je veux dire  c'est pari que
c'est trop lourd à porter ouais en quelque
sorte sur vos épaules pour dire je veux dire je
comprends pourquoi certaines personnes établissent des
liens et nous avions des choses en
commun sur la façon dont nous savons traiter
l'art et la vie et l'ont rendu plus
commun et  plus facile pour les gens des choses
comme ça mais il y a beaucoup de
différences - je veux dire que nous sommes vraiment je veux dire
je n'aurais pas pu faire ce que j'ai fait sans
Andy faisant ce qu'il a fait en premier où
vendent-ils dans votre boutique à New York
appelée pop  acheter principalement tous les imprimés  tu
sais des
t-shirts et des affiches et des jouets des choses
comme ça
surtout des t-shirts tu ne penses pas que
ce genre de marchandisage peut être mauvais
pour ton cœur tu sais que ça peut le
minimiser
non je veux dire tu sais qu'au début
il y avait  les critiques du monde de l'art
et cela a probablement eu un effet sur les
prix du marché de l'art et la même
chose pour Andy quand Engine a fait des films et des
interviews - ouais ouais je veux dire que les
prix des choses d'Andy quand il était
vivant étaient comparés à Jasper Johns  ou
Lichtenstein était très très faible mais qui
s'en soucie vraiment je veux dire je pense que la
valeur réelle d'Andy est beaucoup plus importante
que Lichtenstein notre Jasper fait donc je
veux dire que je ne le fais pas seulement pour l'argent donc
je pense que tu ne sais pas ouais  et de
toute façon pour moi la boutique correspond
exactement à ce que j'ai fait dans le métro
tu sais je veux dire si je n'aurais pas fait
la boutique et puis élitiste et juste un
peintre cher alors je pense que ça
aurait été plus mal et faire  les
choses disponibles quand  là tu penses
aux figures françaises seulement avant comme
diosa de khumba ben tu sais quoi je suis
ami avec musulman je veux dire j'ai rencontré pour la
première fois je pense des bus de revenu des Vosges
et Burnham et Blanchard et Louie
très tôt genre 1982 en 1903 tu aimes
ce qu'ils peignent ouais je pense je
pense qu'il n'y a pas il y a une
sorte de programme international ils ont
grandi ils ont beaucoup des mêmes choses que j'ai
grandi sur si c'était vous ne dessinez jamais
devant votre banque vous ouais
vous avez été directement oh  ouais dessiner
avec de la peinture ouais parce que c'est un direct
et qui fait partie de la raison pour laquelle je suppose
que le pourquoi du nom des
trucs d'artistes 3d parce que même la façon dont je fais des
peintures est d'une manière comme si quelqu'un
faisait du PPT parce qu'il n'y a pas de croquis
ou  une planète c'est juste une plaque rouge de
ta tête à eux tu aimes quand tu
peins des gens qui
te regardent c'est une sorte d'événement tu aimes
beaucoup c'est bien c'est comme quand
tu peignais dans le métro maintenant tu es
o  car après avoir passé
si longtemps dans le métro, je suis devenu beaucoup plus à l'
aise avec ça et maintenant je fais beaucoup
de fois dans des URL à l'extérieur ou dans des écoles
ou des hôpitaux des choses comme ça et et
il y a généralement des gens qui regardent mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas un  problème parce que
vous n'êtes pas vous ne regardez pas les gens
que vous regardez la chose que vous
faites donc et j'ai toujours de la musique joyeuse
et donc je sais juste où
écoutez-vous quand vous travaillez principalement la
danse  la musique comme la musique sur laquelle tu
danserais et j'ai beaucoup d'
amis ce sont des DJ à New York donc les
gens font toujours du goût pour eux
combien vaut une peinture maintenant je ne sais pas
maintenant c'est ridicule en fait ouais
et je suis allé voir le show comme un show à
Paris en ce moment de dessins que je
n'ai pas mis la chemise c'est des dessins que
ce gros dealer a acheté à différents
endroits et c'est incroyable pour moi le
prix qu'il vend pour
combien je veux dire un  beaucoup je suis des centaines de
milliers de dollars
je moi  un quatre petits dessins qui étaient des
autographes que j'ai fait pour des gens comme 25 000 $
et complètement fous pour épouser notre marché
est complètement, je veux dire, il n'a pas de venin, vous
savez, l'équilibre avec la valeur réelle de
quelque chose ouais et pour moi c'est effrayant
parce que j'avais toujours l'habitude de  aller aux vernissages
et je ferais des dessins pour des centaines
de personnes et maintenant ça me fait réfléchir à
deux fois parce que les gens prennent le dessin
et ils les vendent beaucoup d'
argent maintenant c'est fou donc vous ne savez pas
si quand vous signez quelque chose ils
veulent  parce qu'ils le veulent vraiment ou
s'ils pensent juste à l'argent comme
tout le monde pense que c'est comme dessiner des
billets de banque Roumanie ouais et beaucoup de
gens qui collectionnent de l'art en ce moment ne se
soucient même pas de ce que c'est qu'ils ne regardent même pas
le doigt qu'ils sont seulement c'est
comme un placement c'est comme l'
immobilier ou la cote boursière où peut-on voir
vos peintures à Paris en ce moment eh bien
il y a une exposition de ces petits tirages de
dessins que j'ai fait en 1983 qui sont à
cette galerie  appelé 1900 2000 sur la
petite galerie Lu Bonaparte si vous ne continuez pas à
diffuser quel peintre seriez-
vous voudriez-vous être comme la peinture
je veux dire la réponse évidente est piccata
ouais je veux dire tout ce que je veux
être épuisé mais si ce n'était pas ça
qu'eux et puis je suppose et le
choix suivant et si vous deviez donner une
définition de vous-même, que diriez-vous
qu'il y a des artistes dans le vrai sens
du monde, ce qui signifie que vous pouvez faire
tout ce que vous savez, je veux dire que je peux construire des
choses et faire  laissez tomber vous connaissez le sucre et l'
eau et concevez des meubles et construisez des
bâtiments ou le savez-vous juste vraiment
un vrai
Oh